desde que llegaron a berlín maxim
kournikova y más ya managers han tenido
una sola meta devolverle la vida a ecos
de moscú la forma de emisoras de radio
sacada del aire por el kremlin por su
cobertura de la guerra en ucrania pero
como muchos periodistas independientes
salieron de rusia con una visa schengen
que no les da derecho a trabajar en
alemania así que llevan tres meses
esperando por una solución
ni siquiera podemos tener una cuenta
bancaria propia o crear una compañía
porque no tenemos oportunidad de hacerlo
y por eso es todo tan lento pero
esperamos que cuando tengamos la otra
visa sea más sencillo
lijo
[Música]
hay unos 70 periodistas rusos en el
exilio en alemania que los próximos días
deberían recibir visas de larga duración
el gobierno alemán también destinará 3
millones y medio de euros para ayudar a
periodistas y figuras de la oposición
rusa en el exilio en el curso del
próximo año tres meses después de que
estallara la guerra es una solución
satisfactoria aunque lenta en llegar de
acuerdo con el eurodiputado sergei lago
de esquí
todas estas personas representan el
rostro de una rusia mejor y más
democrática una rusia que queremos
ayudar a construir en el futuro
periodistas y disidentes que permanecen
en rusia u otros países podrían pedir
una visa humanitaria para irse a
alemania pero a diferencia de los
ucranianos sus casos serán analizados
uno por uno una distinción que amnistía
internacional considera injusta
hablamos de gente con la que miembros de
nuestro gobierno han tenido contacto
regular en el pasado no entiendo por qué
no podemos encontrar una solución global
para un grupo de personas que no es tan
grande
maxim corn y coffee marcha myers todavía
confían en que el plan del gobierno
ayude otros periodistas rusos a irse a
berlín para fortalecer su equipo echo de
moscú regresará a través de streaming en
internet al final del verano